el salvador's president najib bukelli
last night came out firing with a tweet
he randomly just tweeted out and said
hey guys tomorrow 32 central banks and
12 financial authorities that's 44
countries in total we'll meet in el
salvador to discuss financial inclusion
digital economy banking the unbanked the
bitcoin rollout and its benefits in our
country now this just wasn't a random
tweet he actually put the whole list of
countries on twitter these include
representation from countries like
paraguay ghana uganda madagascar haiti
burundi jordan gambia honduras rwanda
nepal pakistan and of course el salvador
itself now one of the big things to take
away here is that all of these different
countries they're all showing up in el
salvador it's a country with only six
and a half million people in the
population and buchelli has become
famous on the international stage for
going ahead and trying to plug his
country into the bitcoin standard he's
gone ahead and he's actually bought
bitcoin for his country he's installed
over 200 atms around the country they
built a mobile app to allow anyone in
the world to send money to a salvadorian
through that chivo wallet they also are
paying people to download the chiva
wallet in bitcoin and then last but not
least they're creating bitcoin city
they're issuing bitcoin backed bonds and
generally they're just trying to take
their entire country and adopt bitcoin
now there's a lot of people who are
critical of this they think that it's
not gonna work i don't know maybe it
works maybe it doesn't but you gotta
give the man a tip of the cap because
he's got the courage and the conviction
to pursue it now i'm not an expert on
salvadorian politics i don't want to be
so there's plenty of people who have
critiques of his administration but one
thing i do know is sure that regardless
of whether you're a good person a bad
person you've got the best interest or
the worst interest in mind for your
people if you give them bitcoin you
can't use it against them you can't use
it to harm them you can't inflate away
their savings you simply have to operate
with your hands tied behind your back el
salvador was a really interesting case
study because they were dollarized
nation and now that they've made bitcoin
legal tender and they started to adopt
the digital sound money there's a lot of
other countries and there's a lot of
other central banks they want to in on
the game they want to understand what
are you doing why are you doing it how
did you do it and what has been the
learning so far it'll be fascinating to
see what comes out of this 44 different
countries all meeting together in el
salvador but watching so many different
people go ahead and get orange built by
the one national leader who's been
willing
to go ahead and plug his country into
the bitcoin standard i think that's
fascinating and what ultimately is going
to happen here is my guess a lot of
people are going to walk away and
they're going to say maybe we don't need
to go as hard or as fast as el salvador
but maybe we should go ahead and
actually get a little just in case it
catches on satoshi had the foresight to
tell that to people literally a decade
ago and i think it rings true even today
it's gonna be fascinating to watch this
play out bucheli's got 44 countries in
his backyard something tells me
bitcoin's about to come a lot more
popular among countries and central
banks quickly